we are at the first annual 3d film
festival with director Chris Chris
ateliê and the winners of the best pilot
and episodic safety geeks hi everyone
and welcome to 3d FF Hollywood I'm here
with the production team and creative
team from safety gates one of the most
amazing comedic episodic series 3d
projects I've ever seen how you guys
need a great modern oh yeah thank you
thank you so much for joining your phone
here at 3d FF I know the audience really
enjoyed it we certainly enjoyed it the
screening room from the pleasure yeah
would love to ask you the show was
created by Dave peeler and Tom konkle
and guys if you maybe give us a little
insight on the inspiration for the film
twisted genius we are twisted oh really
we set out to do something that we
wanted to say that made us laugh and we
were looking at all the procedural shows
that were out and at the time no one was
kind of doing a goof on this and so we
used it as our page that we hung nobody
on and then created this world and
really it was us learning about the
technology of new media and how to do 3d
that drove us to do this and share it
was possible and the learning curve on
it was vertical I mean really this is a
bunch of friends that got together and
made a show it's amazing for us to be
even screening is an honor and yet you
know this is wonderful so so really I
think it's a labor of love that also
gave us with new tools that we can play
with and know how to make a job very
much and this is storm elstead it did
visual effects on the show and Michael
Smith he did visual effects and was our
chief stereo refer he did all the work
making this into 3ds so that we could
enjoy and without these guys wouldn't be
right well I have to say one of the
reasons you're getting this award is
because your level and skill in creating
high quality
3d images was well surpass and higher
than the average and we could you guys
did a great job so kudos to both of you
your Thank You mayor Dennis and this top
is quads egg we love doing 3d in the
service of comedy yes we think that's a
really cool place yeah there's too many
epics too many other things we like it
in the service of embarrassment and
slapstick let's face it there's 3d for
everyone yeah now we also have brittany
Powell the star of the film so pretty
high these guys had a space of Shona
star who you look at the 3d its
Brittney's world we live in it is a
collab with these clowns hmm I started
stalking Tom yes a couple years ago yeah
so eventually he had to invite me in
yeah i thought i was being pumped
because I we were at an audition we're
both actors and she and I talked to her
me laughing oh my gosh you know she's
amazing and she'd be perfect for the
show and she pulls up next to my card is
like hey we gotta do something I'm like
where's Ashton being punk no we became
fast friends and so it was so organic
which I think the most creative stuff is
house where she ended up being smart
funny intelligent and just she was if we
were to draw a character we would have
drawn her but what's amazing is we had
already written the character she plays
and Anton alam khan said what we need to
find is a Playboy model who has a great
sense of humor has comic timing but get
this and we'll talk to me and we found
just talked to ya so that's a case of
something going right yeah and she was
wonderful in it and she has amazing
comic chops and really the show is is
hot on the performances of it it really
is it is utterly believable to me and
I've watched it so many times because
you never really catch them acting they
really believe ya insanity and I think
that's a testament to what everybody did
because you're acting in a complete
vacuum there was nothing there
everything the show's been positive yeah
Michelle on green screen so aside from
the things actually touched or the other
actors you might be working with or
touched or touch 5 that's the cost of
life oh okay you normally work to get
ahead yep oh yeah it was very much a
like working in the theater where a lot
of it suggested not there because then
it was composited and placed in later
why these guys right and then one thing
I think is really amazing is we've
decided to kind of go forward with doing
3d and and our guys who do tech have
these wicked sense of humor and at one
point Mike goes well who better to go to
business within a comedy team I've been
doing visual effects sure so I think
that everyone shows it up comedian yeah
it makes it palatable and we just enjoy
each other's time because it's so work
intensive and so I enjoy everyone's
company here I'm honored absolutely well
on behalf of the 3d FF board of
directors i would like to present you
with your award thank you thank you so
much that's fantastic that's very into
joint in this way then it's reading here
and your talk and now it drops okay
shoot that's what you're gonna find that
in life oh yeah there you go there's an
award in that job gentlemen by the cast
and production team from safety gates